Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Barto Kratz.
Können Sie bitte wieder abholen? Ich habe vielleicht einen Akustik.
Ja. B-A-R-T-O-Barto, mein Name.
B-A-R-A-T-Z, Kratz.
Okay. Herr Kratz, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Herr Kratz, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
6. Juni 1970.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter und 68.
68, ja? Okay. Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 70 Kilo.
Okay. Danke für die Information, Herr Kratz. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, Doktor. Ich bin heute zu Ihnen gekommen, weil ich habe sehr starke Rückenschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe seit 6 Monaten.
Okay. Herr Kratz, wo genau diese Schmerzen? Ich meine, Mittelrücken oder rechte Seite, linke Seite?
Ja, Doktor. Diese Schmerzen sind guterformig.
Okay. Und streiten diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Immer ganz guterformig.
Okay, ich verstehe. Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Also sind Sie eher drückend, stechend, dumpf?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind krampartig, Doktor.
Krampartig, okay. Und sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg? Ich meine, wellenformig zum Beispiel?
Ja, immer diese Schmerzen dauerhaft. Aber manchmal verschlimmert, manchmal verbessert.
Bisschen verleumt für mich, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Herr Kratz, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht, 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Die Schmerzen sind 8 von 10, Doktor.
Okay, das ist eine starke Schmerzen. Herr Kratz, soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende der Sprechen aushalten?
Ich bin ein bisschen geduldig, Doktor.
Okay, bitte sagen Sie mir sofort Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Schmerzmittel benötigen, okay?
Okay, danke schön.
Ich werde mich beeilen, ja.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen, haben Sie bemerkt? Wie zum Beispiel eine Körperhaltung oder Essen oder stressige Situation?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verschlimmert oder lindert?
Immer verschlimmert.
Immer schlimmer geworden, ja?
Ja, ja.
Ich verstehe. Und sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Kratz, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Okay, und waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten, ich meine, beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja, ich bin beim Arzt gegangen, aber er hat mir gesagt, ich habe Magenprobleme und sie hat mir eine Medikamente eingenommen.
Aber das ist nicht geholfen, Doktor.
Magenschutz, meinen Sie?
Ja.
Kennen Sie den Namen von diesem Medikament oder?
Ich erinnere mich nicht, nein.
Okay. Herr Kratz, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Sanatci.
Okay. Ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren für diese Details, ja?
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, und haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten außer diesen Magenschutz-Tabletten noch andere Medikamente wie zum Beispiel Schmerzmittel eingenommen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe viele Mal eine Ibuprofen-Tablette eingenommen, aber das hat mir nicht geholfen.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Ibuprofen?
Ja, 500 mg.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay. Herr Kratz, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Hautfarbeveränderung, wie zum Beispiel Gelbsucht, bemerkt?
Ja, Doktor. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass meine Haut gelb geworden ist.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Bauchschmerzen, Herr Kratz?
Bauchschmerzen? Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nur Hörnukenschmerzen, ja?
Ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Veränderung mit dem Stuhlgang oder mit dem Urin bemerkt? Ich meine...
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich erinnere, mein Urin ist dunkel und der Stuhlgang ist hell, weiß und fett.
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt. Aber mein Stuhlgang ist hell.
Okay, alles klar.
Leiden Sie unter Juckreiz?
Ja, seit ein paar Wochen habe ich außerdem starken Juckreiz am Rücken, ja.
Okay. Herr Kratz, haben Sie vergrößerte Lymphknoten in der Achselhöhle oder in dem leichten Bereich bemerkt oder am Hals?
Ich habe nicht unter suchen, Doktor. Ich bin nicht Arzt. Aber ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay, alles klar. Leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen?
Ich habe keine Desebechwerden, nein.
Okay. Und darf ich fragen, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Das freut mich. Herr Kratz, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Übel, erbrechen? Ja, nein Doktor.
Okay. Und haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder besonders Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Pech?
Nein, ich habe keinen Apathit, Doktor. Ich habe keinen Apathit.
Okay. Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich abgenommen?
In den letzten sechs Monaten habe ich etwa zwölf Kilogramm abgenommen.
Okay.
Aber ich denke, deswegen meine Apathitlosigkeit. Aber ich bin nicht sicher, nein.
Okay. Wir werden recherchieren. Machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke schön. Schlafen Sie gut?
Wegen dieser Schmerzen schlafe ich nicht gut.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich denke, dass ich durchschlafen habe.
Okay. Herr Kratz, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Bauchspeicheldrüse, Probleme?
Ja, ich habe seit etwa 15 Jahren Bluthochdruck. Ich nehme dafür Atorvastatin, allerdings nur einmal täglich 10 Milligramm.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das richtig mache, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Kratz, normalerweise verschreiben wir Atorvastatin gegen erhöhte Blutfettwerte. Haben Sie dieses Problem?
Ja, ich habe natürlich Bluthochdruck. Aber diese Medikamente meiner Nachbarin habe ich. Sie hat mir diese Medikamente gegeben.
Also Herr Kratz, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, nehmen Sie Atorvastatin 10 Milligramm ohne ärztlichen Rat ein, richtig?
Ja, meine Nachbarin hat mir gesagt, dass ist sehr gut für Bluthochdruck. Ich nehme von meiner Nachbarin ein.
Okay. Herr Kratz, die Einnahme von Medikamenten ohne ärztlichen Rat kann für Sie sehr gefährlich sein. Ich empfehle Ihnen Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig besuchen, okay?
Ja Doktor, ich nehme falsche Medikamente in der Oda.
Ja, ich denke so. Aber wir werden diese Situation nochmal kontrollieren, okay?
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, Sie leiden an Bluthochdruck, Sie haben gesagt. Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente dagegen ein oder nur Atorvastatin?
Nur Atorvastatin. Aber außerdem wurde bei mir vor einigen Jahren eine Hyperkolesterolämie festgestellt, Doktor.
Okay, und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich habe nicht viele Fettige essen, ja. Mit Diät.
Sie haben nur Diät, okay. Noch etwas? Andere Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Ich habe keine anderen Erkrankungen, nein.
Okay, das freut mich. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich wurde mit sechs Jahren am Blutdarm operiert.
Und vor etwa zehn Jahren habe ich eine Schraube in der rechten Hand bekommen.
Genauso gesagt wegen einem Arbeitsunfall, ja.
Okay.
In der nächsten Woche habe ich einen Termin für eine Kataraktoperation.
Derzeit bin ich dafür auch wieder getroffen, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Kraz, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Außer Atorvastatin, ich meine.
Ich nehme andere Medikamente, nein, keine anderen Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich reagiere allergisch auf Birkenpollen.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Die äußert sich mit einer Rhinokonjunktivität und auf Ausstopp und Katzenhaare.
Da bekomme ich rote Augen und eine laufende Nase und trennende Augen und Yukreis, ja.
Okay. Herr Kraz, rauchen Sie?
Rauchen? Ja, Doktor, ich rauche leider.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Ich rauche 10 Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren? Ja.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke jeden Tag etwa zwei bis drei Flaschen Bier.
Okay, nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, in meiner Jugend zwischen 18 und 20 Jahren habe ich ein paar Mal Haschisch ausprobiert, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Kraz, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen von Birkenpollen?
Mein Vater hatte eine Magengeschwür. Meine Mutter leidet an Zuckerkrankenheit.
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes und Fusssindrom. Sie leidet im Pflegeheim.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Leider. Meine Schwester hatte einen Kolonkarzinom, der operiert wurde.
Außerdem hat meine Mutter eine chronische Pankreatitis.
Okay, Herr Kraz, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Wohnen Sie alleine?
Ja, ich wohne alleine.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Tiefbauarbeiter.
Okay. Herr Kraz, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich? Ich habe starke Rückenschmerzen.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Kraz. Es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit der Bauchspeicheldrüse haben.
Ich werde zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann kann ich ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Doktor, ich habe viel Angst. Meine Schwester hatte einen Kolonkarzinom.
Ich habe viel Angst über Krebs.
Aber ich habe Krebs.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Kraz. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Also ohne weitere Untersuchungen kann ich leider keine bestimmte Diagnose bezüglich Krebses abgeben.
Zuerst müssen wir diese Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Danach können wir über Ihre aktuellen Fragen widersprechen.
Aber Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus und sind in guten Händen bei uns. Wir werden alles für Sie tun.
Aber ich habe viele Kilogramm in der Kurszeit abgenommen. Ich habe viel Angst, Doktor.
Sie haben recht. Aber Sie wissen, Herr Kraz, Ihre Beschwerden haben andere Gründe.
Sie haben auch Appetitlosigkeit.
Das kann für diese Gewichtsabnahme eine Ursache sein.
Wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Der Krebs ist nicht 100% erblich.
Danke schön, Doktor. Ich war sehr froh.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, Herr Kraz.
Danke schön.
Die Basifaler haben sich auf Krebsen befestigt.
Du hast eine gute Antwort, aber ich habe die Frage wieder gebeten.
Sie sind auf dem Weg.
Herr Doktor, so farben Sie die Fragen.
Sie haben die Frage, ob ich in der Kurszeit in Krebs sein werde.
Die Fragen sind wie klassisch.
Ja, ich glaube, die beiden sind klassisch.
Ich kümmer mich um.
Okay, die Sitzung geht weiter. Ich gehe weiter.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Herr Bartok Kraz ist 54 Jahre alt, 1,68 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Kraz stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit sechs Monaten bestehender, persistierender Rückenschmerzen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien krampfartig und wellensförmig.
Und er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen güterformig seien.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzskala mit 8 von 10 bewertet.
Und die vielmalige Einnahme von Ibuprofen 500 Milligramm hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er früher wegen dieser Schmerzen bei seinem Hausarzt gewesen war.
Und er habe dagegen Antacid-Tabletten eingenommen.
Der Name von Tabletten sollte geklärt werden.
Der Patient berichtete über Icterus, dunkler Urin, Pulitis seit ein paar Wochen am Rücken.
Und Statole, die Fragen nach Lymphadrenopathie, Angina Pectoris, Tachikadi, Trussis und Lispne wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Inapetens, Gewichtsabnahme von 12 Kilogramm innerhalb von 6 Monaten und Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte er seit 15 Jahren bestehende Altery hypertonie und seit einem Jahr bestehende Hyperkolesthylamine.
Der Patient nehme Otolastatin 10 Milligramm ohne ärztlichen Rat und er mache eine Diät gegen Hyperkolesthylamine.
Mit 16 Jahren sei bei ihm eine Apendektomie durchgeführt worden.
Vor 10 Jahren habe er sich eine rechten Hand Verletzung bei einem Arbeizunfall zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
Der Patient hat einen Operationtermin nächste Woche wegen Katarakt.
Momentan benutzt er ein Augentropfen dagegen.
Er hat Beacon-Pollen-Allergie, die sich durch Rhinoconjunktivitis äußert.
Er hat Hausstab-Allergie und Katzenhaare-Allergie, die sich durch Rhinoconjunktivitis und Pulitis äußert.
Er ist Raucher. Er raucht seit 20 Jahren 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinkt 2-3 Flaschen Bier täglich und im Jugend habe der Patient zwischen 18. und 20. Lebensjahr ein paar Mal Haschisch probiert.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater an Ulcus ventriculi leide und die Mutter leide an Diabetes mellitus, Diabetische Fuß und Chronische Pankreatitis.
Die Eltern des Patienten wohnen in einem Pflegeheim.
Er habe eine Schwester, die an Kolonkarzinom leide und sie sei wegen Kolonkarzinom operiert worden.
Er sei geschieden, habe kein Kind und wohne alleine. Er sei Tiefbauarbeiter von dem Hof.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf ein Pankreatkarzinom aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Rückenschmerzen, guterformige Rückenschmerzen, Echterus, Stratore, dunkler Urin, Gewichtsabnahme von 12 kg innerhalb von 6 Monaten.
Diese Symptome sprechen für ein Pankreatkarzinom.
Als Differenzdiagnosen kommen Chronische Pankreatitis, Schole Lithiasis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Differenzparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Echterus und andere Hautfarbeveränderungen, Acides, Druckschmerzen am Bauch vorhanden sind oder vergrößerte Lymphknoten vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Tumormarkers, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Amylase, Lipase, Gerinnungsparameter, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine CT des Abdomens mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Danach würde ich eine PET-CT durchführen, um die möglichen Metastasen genau zu überprüfen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und den Patienten einen venösen Zugang legen.
Ich würde Analgetika verbreiten und ein Onkologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine EACP durchführen, um die mögliche Gallengang- oder Pankreatikagangsteine zu überprüfen und gleichzeitig zu entfernen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine PET-CT durchführen würden. Können Sie uns die PET-CT aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde sie über PET-CT aufklären.
Der PET-CT gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren. Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Entzündungen, Tumore und Metastasen genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig chemisch frei.
Bei dieser Untersuchung verbreiten wir eine leichte radioaktive Substanz.
Dann warten wir ungefähr eine Stunde für die Verteilung der Stoffe regelmäßig in den Körper.
Dann machen wir eine CT-Scanning. Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in einer CT-Röhre ruhig liegen.
Wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten eine Berührungsmittel geben.
Vor der Untersuchung soll der Patient sechs Stunden nicht mehr essen oder trinken.
Es gibt einige Kontraindikationen, wie z.B. Schwangerschaft.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient viel Wasser trinken, um die radioaktiven Stoffe schnell auszuscheiden.
Der Patient soll mit den schwangeren Personen oder Kindern kontaktieren, um zu vermeiden.
Herr Kollegen, ist es möglich, in diesem Falle gallen Blase zu mögen?
Der Patient leidet an Icterus, Piritus, Statura und dunkler Urin.
Das bedeutet, es gibt eine Staubung der Gallenblasen.
In diesem Fall würden Sie eine RCP durchführen?
Eine RCP würde sinnvoll bei diesem Patienten sein. Wir können eine Steine genau beurteilen und wir können gleichzeitig diesen Stein entfernen.
Ich habe keine Frage heute.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberhans. Sie sind wirklich sehr nett. Danke.